إذن هذه هي أمتعتي ، هذه هي
حقيبتي الشخصية التي سترونني أتنقل فيها
عبر العديد من المطارات مع أنني شخص صلب
الجانب ، لقد حققت قفزة أعلم أن
هناك مثل الجانب الناعم من الأشخاص مقابل
الجانب الصعب الذي سأفتحه  في الوقت الحالي ،
لا يحب الناس الجانب الصعب لأنه
ينقسم في المنتصف ويعتقدون أن كل
أغراضهم ستسقط ، لذا من
المهم حقًا الحصول على حقيبة جانبية
صلبة بها مقصورات كما ترون ،
أستخدم مكعبات التعبئة أعتقد أنه يمكنك
تعامل أكثر مع المكعبات وأنا أحب كيف أن هذا يحتوي
على الجزء العلوي الواضح حتى ترى كل البنطال الذي
لا أقوم بتكديس الأشياء التي أقوم بتدويرها
ووضعها ثم ينزلق هذا المكعب في
الواقع في درج فندق
أو في مقصورة الرحلات البحرية أو  منزل عمتك ماري ،
لذا أقوم بإلغاء خطوة ، انظر إلى تلك
الغرفة التي تريد ملء تلك
المساحة بأشياء أصغر ، لذلك أحب أن أضع
مثل اللباس الداخلي ، ملابس النوم الخاصة بي ، الملابس الداخلية
للرجال ، يمكنك وضع رابطاتك هنا أي شيء
لملء ذلك ، وبعد ذلك  ضع
مكعب التعبئة الخاص بي هناك حتى يكون ذلك
أعطني مساحة هنا حيث تجدها
، دائمًا ما تسافر نصيحة السفر الكبيرة الأخرى الخاصة بي
مع الأشياء القديمة التي يمكنك تركها
خلفك ، أي أحذية رياضية للجري ، لذلك
لدينا دائمًا هذا السؤال ، هل سأقوم
بالركض ربما سيكون لدي وقت للذهاب  إلى
صالة الألعاب الرياضية ، لكننا نعلم أن الأحذية الرياضية تشغل
مساحة كبيرة جدًا ، لكن هذه الأحذية فقط اذهب
هنا في حقيبتي ، لكن إذا حصلت على
هدية رائعة حقًا شيء لأمي أو
أطفالي ، فهذه هي أول من
يذهب ، لذا احضرها  العناصر التي أحضرها الآن لم أحضر سوى
ثلاثة أزواج من الأحذية ، وزوجًا رائعًا
من الأحذية أو تعلمون ما إذا كنت
سأخرج لشراء حذائي الرياضي ثم الأحذية
التي أرتديها عندما أعبر
المطار ، فلا
بأس بذلك الآن سأذهب  لتظهر لك كنزتين كبيرتين من
الصوف والسترات الصوفية
السميكة بأعناق سميكة الآن ، هذان عنصران
لن تحزمهما أبدًا.
يمكنك القيام بذلك الآن
سأقوم بضغطه وأخذ حمام  k في هذا لا يناسب أي
مشكلة ولكنك تعتقد أننا سننتظر
دقيقة الآن لن يكون مناسبًا
والحاوية العلوية لم تعد الآن
بحجم
محمول ، فقط تستخدم القابل للتوسيع والآن عاد إلى
الحجم المحمول